Tonight, we're getting
more details about the explosion
at a crucial bridge linking the U.S.
and Canada.
The FBI saying tonight
that there is no connection to terrorism
in that fiery car crash
and that no explosive materials
were found at the scene.
Instead, we're learning that a 2022
Bentley two door
coupe entered from the U.S.
side and quickly accelerated
before hitting a curb and going airborne.
Now, Governor
Hochul says a resident
from western New York
was involved in that crash.
But in the hours before,
we had a clear picture
of what was going on here,
it didn't stop one network
from linking it to possible terror.
What I've been told is that this was
an attempted terrorist attack.
They believe the two people in that car
who are now both dead
after that
large explosion
there have
packed that car full of explosives.
As for what types of explosives?
We're not sure just yet.
We don't know how long
the people
who perpetrated
this attack have been in this country.
Did they come into the country legally?
Did they come across
illegally and claim asylum
where they
some of the nearly 1 million got aways
who've come into this country?
Remember that
most of these terrorist organizations,
they're Gen Z, right. They're wrong.
If you look at the
if you look at what Hamas
puts out online, online
on Tik Tok, they're very sophisticated.
It could be that
these people were just inspired.
It's pretty easy to figure out
how to do this online. Unfortunately.
And joining me now for more
on this is CNN's Oliver Darcy Oliver.
Wow.
I mean,
what can you tell us about
how long they were
reporting this as a terror attack
so confidently
and how many people this bad information
could have reached?
Yeah, I mean,
this was irresponsible reporting.
This was reckless reporting.
And by all accounts,
it was inaccurate reporting.
We now know that the governor
saying there was no indication
that there was a terrorist attack.
But that's not what Fox News
initially reported
and reported for hours.
I want to give you a sense of
of how they reported this early on
in the afternoon.
They sent a push alert
to all their
mobile phones, people
with mobile app installed
and it said that the New York vehicle
explosion is attempt a terror attack
according to sources of theirs.
They plastered this on the front page
of their highly trafficked website.
And, of course,
Fox is a very highly rated channel.
So millions of people
probably saw this information
just from Fox News alone.
And of course,
then there's the word of mouth factor.
So a lot of people were misinformed
by this inaccurate report.
And that's
why Fox News
really owes
their audience and everyone else
a correction.
But they still have
not actually issued a correction.
You know,
they quietly edited out the huge mistakes
on their digital online pieces.
The correspondent
who inaccurately reported this,
she went on air
and walked back
the reporting while basically
blaming her sources
for bad information,
taking no responsibility
of her own for this.
And that's really what separates Abby,
I think, a real credible news
organization, one that you can trust
from a outlet that really doesn't
have much credibility these days
and reporting facts.
When you make a mistake,
you're transparent, the audience.
Fox is not doing that.
They made a bad mistake
and they're really hiding,
hiding from it.
And it penetrated even to,
you know, political figures, people
like Vivek Ramaswamy,
who actually saw him in one of those
clips, and Kerry Lake out in Arizona.
They amplified the claim
that this could be terror on
social media.
That was wrong, too.
And it had real impacts.
That was definitely wrong.
And, you know, if you look at Vivek's
page, you know, all those tweets about
the border
and possible terror attack,
those are still live on his on his page.
And he's a guy who purports
to apparently care about the truth.
Why hasn't he corrected this to his
to his audience?
You know, and Fox News
itself,
they were talking about Islamic terrorism
on the air.
I mean, this was not a small mistake.
This was a huge mistake.
If it was happening
at a serious news organization, if,
say, The New York Times or CNN
had made a mistake like this,
there would be a huge autopsy.
People would be suspended,
maybe lose their jobs over this.
But, you know, in the right wing
information space,
there really is little accountability
for getting stories wrong.
Even if you get them this wrong.
Yeah, I mean, it
fit a particular narrative.
It just turned out that narrative
wasn't true.
Oliver Darcy,
thank you so much for coming in for us.